Let's think a little more carefully
about how the NavigationController is
keeping track of ViewControllers.
A navigation controller has
a stack of ViewControllers.
Remember that a stack is
a Last-In-First-Out data structure,
like a stack of cups.
It has two operations.
Items are popped off of the stack,
and items are pushed onto the stack.
When we start the Settings app,
the top level settings page is
displayed with the title, Settings.
If we click on Notifications,
a new ViewController gets
pushed onto the stack.
We can choose to push a number
of different views next.
Phone, Messages, Passbook.
Now the stack is three
ViewControllers deep.
We only have one choice
if we want to pop.
That corresponds to the Back button.
You can see here beside the Back button
that the navigation bar shows the title
of the next ViewController on the stack.
In this case,
it's the Settings ViewController.